[Music]
marijuana legalization is moving quickly
23 states have either legalized
recreational weed entirely
decriminalized possession to some degree
or have legalized medical marijuana so
what is the future of legal weed
privateer holdings has raised 82 million
dollars to invest in weed startups some
predict that legal marijuana could grow
into a forty billion dollar a year
industry and that it could generate up
to seven billion a year in taxes
legalization could even cut Mexican drug
cartel profits by up to 30 percent
mexican leads wholesale prices as much
as a quarter is expensive as it was
before the wave of legalization why in
part because US weed is often more
potent than its Mexican counterparts
with 10 to 20 percent THC compared to 3
to 8 percent south of the border the
future of marijuana also includes lots
of cool products like marijuana lemonade
a vaporizer designed by an apple
developer marijuana infused sex lube and
of course plenty of innovative edibles
and there are apps massroots and weed
maps allow pot smokers to connect with
dispensaries and each other pot biotics
is developing an algorithmic app to
recommend medical marijuana strains to
patients and grasp cannery and E's are
only delivery apps now that's capitalism
marijuana's medical potential has
definitely helped the legalization
movement it is used to treat or
alleviate symptoms of clock coma
seizures anxiety Alzheimer's multiple
sclerosis muscle spasms Crohn's disease
arthritis Parkinson's PTSD and pain from
cancer and cancer treatments and only 6%
of marijuana studies investigate its
health benefits so there may be many
more undiscovered medical applications
won't all this good legal weed makes
more people smoke pot possibly Colorado
jumped from having the seventh highest
percentage of regular users of marijuana
to the second highest during
legalization that said nearly 50% of
Americans have already tried marijuana
and maybe that's not such a bad thing
considering that marijuana is far safer
than any other recreational drug and 114
times less deadly than alcohol so get
ready for a new era of legal weed and
remember you don't have to inhale
and if you want more wired videos just
click Subscribe it's good